me alegra mucho poder participar en este
foro incluso aunque es un excepcional
por muchas razones primero porque
estamos viviendo durante una pandemia
nunca había sido necesario reemplazar
los encuentros personales con encuentros
virtuales pero ahora no podemos
encontrarnos en persona tenemos que
hacerlo de esta manera pero déjenme
pasar a lo que dije hace dos años cuando
cité alexander con humboldt
él dijo que todo funciona en la acción
bueno hace siglos él entendió lo que
llamamos un multilateralismo él entendió
que era la base de nuestra actividad
política que debería ser la base creo
que los últimos dos años han dejado muy
claro
esta creencia en el multilateralismo es
el revivir de la lucha contra las
pandemias bueno lo dejado bastante claro
pero desde la oim se nos dijo entonces
en los minutos que si no os podemos
asegurar de que todos estén vacunados
200 virus no es vencido en todo el mundo
nadie estará a salvo nadie tendrá la
posibilidad de estar a salvo del virus
porque habrá mutaciones una y otra vez
debemos asegurarnos que todos en el
mundo
tengan acceso a la vacuna rápidamente
después de ese encuentro del g7 alemania
ha defendido el respaldo por el
acelerador hacer té y el programa de
vacunación kóvacs hemos prometido 2.5
mil millones
de dosis que el programa tendrá a su
disposición creemos realmente en esto en
estos programas respecto del cambio
climático
el tema diversidad la lucha contra el
terrorismo incluso más urgente
esta los objetivos de sostenibilidad que
deben ser logrados para 2020 todos estos
objetivos deben ser cumplidos si unimos
puede ser cumplido si unimos nuestras
fuerzas en todos los campos en nuestro
concepto de seguridad y es algo que
usted embajadora mencionó hace años y lo
ha seguido haciendo en los últimos años
este es un concepto de seguridad
multidimensional interesada
este año los aspectos son mucho mejores
de lo que solían ser tiene mucho que ver
con yo vaivén siendo el nuevo presidente
de los eeuu de américa
en su discurso acaba de anunciar que su
administración ha tomado pasos y hemos
visto que no son palabras sino que han
tomado acción han vuelto al acuerdo
climático de parís a la organización
mundial de salud del consejo de derechos
humanos
también han estado listos
para ti
revivir el acuerdo nuclear contra esos
son pasos muy importantes para una
cooperación mundial y yo solamente
puedo respaldarlo en lo que dice depende
de los países democráticos hacer esto no
solamente hablar de la libertad o de los
valores sino de dar resultados y para
contribuir en todo el mundo en alemania
decimos que no es suficiente con decir
buenas palabras hablar de buenos gestos
sino que es necesario lograrlos la
cooperación transatlántica juega un
papel muy importante que significa esto
para alemania y alemania como país que
ha respaldado siempre la cooperación
trasatlántica como miembro de la unión
europea para nosotros significa que
debemos seguir con el compromiso en
varios campos y debemos asegurarnos de
tomar acción donde sea difícil debemos
luchar debemos superar esos obstáculos
y creo que hemos logrado un gran
progreso en los últimos 2014 en galés
discutimos la promesa de inversión de 2
por ciento cuando se trata de el gasto
de defensa nos comprometimos
con trabajar en esa dirección y hoy debo
decir que estamos en 1.5 por ciento lo
hemos logrado este año en 2014 teníamos
1.1
y seguimos comprometidos con la meta de
2 % y seguiremos trabajando en esa
dirección por supuesto todo depende
de que más se pueda contribuir en esta
alianza transatlántica y me gustaría
resaltar que hemos jugado un papel
importante y avanza por los últimos 18
años en el norte del país estamos
ayudando a crear y proteger la
estabilidad
y también está agradecida por el hecho
de que la administración estadounidense
haya establecido una asesoría sobre pues
ese pase lo que instale alemania está
preparada para permanecer si está en los
intereses del éxito de la misión y si el
resultado es una misión que ayuda a las
fuerzas democráticas y pacíficas
el retiro no significa que no debe
significar que las fuerzas cerradas
dominen de nuevo
somos una estamos trabajando fuertemente
del iter y estamos luchando contra el
terrorismo islámico estamos
comprometidos en irak y alemania por
supuesto está comprometida con la otan
como una relación central de
y creemos
que estos aspectos se complementan no se
oponen no se compiten se complementan y
pertenecen juntos nuestro interés como
unión europea es a veces más importante
que otros por supuesto no estamos por
mis en europa en africa o en siria
son países
que están muy cercanos a europa que está
en nuestro vecindario y por supuesto
nos afecta particularmente lo que ocurre
y en años recientes hemos incrementado
nuestro compromiso en áfrica
incluso aunque sabemos que francia carga
la mayor parte del peso allí aún así
estamos involucrados en la misión misma
de la unión europea entrenamiento de
fuerzas armadas en mali y también en
níger y también hemos respaldado al g7
yo quisiera discutir esto con los eeuu
de américa
cómo podemos ayudar a estos países en su
lucha contra el terrorismo
si no tuviéramos el capítulo 7 de las
naciones unidas y podría ayudar a
nuestros países respaldarlos en su lucha
en su difícil lucha contra el terrorismo
nuestra relación con áfrica es de gran
significado estratégico naturalmente
debe ser un tema muy importante las
discusiones las artísticas uno de los
temas centrales
cuando se trata de vencer al terrorismo
islámico es la duda de que ocurre en
libia
[Música]
hemos tomado más responsabilidad y
pláticas ahí me alegra decir que hemos
tenido cierto éxito en este proceso pero
no debemos ser inocentes hay un gran
peligro de que libia se convierta en el
campo de juego de poderes peligrosos
importantes sin tener realmente una
perspectiva para el pueblo libio la
unión europea está intentando ayudarles
pero la alianza transatlántica también
debería asegurarse de que el futuro del
país leve
y dependa del pueblo libio debemos
respaldar el proceso constitucional
que está liderado por las naciones
unidas es siria porque en siria
solamente puede haber una solución
pacífica sí bueno si toda la gente tiene
que irse del país como era un futuro
político del país por supuesto también
compraremos de manera cercana cuando se
trata con el trato nuclear con irán
esperamos que todavía haya una
oportunidad para ese trato la alianza
tres técnicas diez de dos temas
importantes que debe enfrentar
necesitamos una alianza conjunta uno de
ellos en nuestra relación con rusia
cuando se trata de integridad de nuestro
industria realmente no hemos hecho
ningún progreso en los últimos años el
proceso de minsk
es un instrumento diplomático que puede
ser usado pero
no ha sido exitoso
y rusia
he causado
conflictos híbridos reiteradamente se
han involucrado nuevos estados también
necesitamos una agenda para reducción
agenda conjunta debemos ofrecer
cooperación por un lado pero por el otro
lado debemos ser claros sobre las
diferencias que tenemos y solo puedo
estar de acuerdo con el presidente de
eeuu sobre la pregunta sobre sobre la
inquietud de unidad europea parece por
supuesto esto no es sólo acción de rusia
hay algo que es más complejo
necesitamos una agenda conjunta al
respecto con china respecto de china
china por un lado es un competidor pero
por el otro lado necesitamos que china
resuelva temas globales como el cambio
climático la biodiversidad y otros en
años recientes china
ha ganado más poder en el escenario
internacional y nosotros como alianza
transatlántica como países democráticos
debemos reaccionar a ellos así que la
inquietud sobre la entrega de vacunas no
solo de china o rusia a países en
desarrollo
esa es una duda importante también la
inquietud de que podemos hacer a través
de covas a través de esfuerzos
multilaterales y de la comunidad como el
g7 que podemos hacer para que los países
en desarrollo en áfrica y en otros lados
puedan lograr progreso como pueden las
organizaciones multilaterales como el
marco mundial
lado ms el imf deben ser fortalecidos
una vez más cuando somos débiles cuando
somos lentos para reaccionar lentos para
lograr cambios
y las estructuras subsidiarias en asia
frecuentemente han sido creadas por
china o lideradas por china debemos
tomar acción y mostrar que tenemos algo
por ofrecer juntos debemos definir los
desafíos estratégicos la gente es clara
debemos encontrar formas de hacer esto
unidos nuestros intereses no siempre van
a hacer convergencia debemos ser claros
cuando haya diferencias debemos discutir
las
pero los principios básicos nuestra
creencia en la democracia
ahí estamos en un acuerdo tenemos unas
bases conjuntas y podemos construir a
partir de ahí debemos dejar claro que no
queremos que los países dependen de
nosotros queremos
y ayudar a otros y llevarles nuestros
valores
la alianza transatlántica está en el
núcleo de este esfuerzo solamente puedo
decir que hay mucho por hacer alemania
está lista para un nuevo capítulo la
alianza transatlántica estamos listos me
alegra mucho decir
que estamos listos aquí en este consejo
seguridad